[Musique]
mater s'allège l'épée masque sur les
yeux à temps même à ce curieux mais
attention les yeux j'ai des relations
qui disent ah
oui
j'avais peur d'avoir un talent à
quoi vas-y kovalev à
quoi
la
bonne fête à tous qu'ils veulent ça en
place commission une tradition
[Musique]
tu acceptes pourquoi c'est moi qui
semblait plus tôt
on savait où mick mec je boite c'est
norman fait tout faux pas bouger la tête
sinon ça explose je vais vous expliquer
comment éviter que deux mois déjà la
première erreur ne pas commettre c'est
de prendre de l'aspirine parce que ça va
aggraver vos problèmes la prévention
passe par un verre d'eau entre deux
verres d'alcool pourquoi parce que le
mal de tête le genre le casque à pointe
qui tournaient vers l'intérieur le
lendemain matin c'est dû à la
déshydratation dans le cerveau c'est ça
qui donne mal à la tête je vous le
répète un verre d'eau entre deux verres
d'alcool et après ça ira bien